FoxNews and Donald Trump are very tied
together we know Trump loves Fox and
Friends Fox and Friends in fact is so
watched by Trump that Fox & Friends has
this kind of de facto agenda-setting
power as a result we also know that
Donald Trump and Sean Hannity have night
time phone calls where they chat and
then Hannity puts Trump to bed and then
Trump I guess goes to bed and tweets for
a little while before going to sleep we
also know that fox news plays
prominently in Trump's propaganda
o'clock file twice a day Trump gets this
file from staffers with positive reports
about him and of course a lot of those
come from Fox News and now there is the
I guess we can call it the formalization
of a relationship between the Trump
administration and Fox News because
reports say that former Fox News
executive bill shine is going to be
hired as the at this point I don't know
if it's the 5th 6th or 7th White House
communications director spends on how
many times you decide to count Sean
Spicer because he held the position then
came back as the acting communications
the wreck I count that twice I mean I
think that it's probably the 5th or 6th
maybe even this I don't know anyway the
last person to have the seats the the
position was hope Hicks the position has
been open since March and now bill shine
is coming in bill shine is a
representative of the sexual assault
crisis that Fox News suffered from he
hasn't been directly accused of sexual
assault but he did resign in the midst
of CEO Roger Ailes and host Bill
O'Reilly being slammed with allegations
of sexual assault and we sort of have
the understanding that even if bill
shine wasn't personally involved in any
sexual assault he was probably looking
the other way about many staff reports
of sexual harassment and in a sense it's
kind of perfect that bill shine becomes
the communications director for Trump
you've got a guy who also has more than
a dozen sexual assault allegations
against him in Donald Trump and then you
bring in bill shine who can look the
other way about Trump's sexual
impropriety after looking the other way
about the sexual impropriety of Fox News
employees so in a sense it's like a
perfectly fitting match and it is the
continued formalization of what Fox has
been doing for a very long time now
sort of was running communications for
the White House already Fox and Friends
was a mouthpiece for Trump which Trump
followed Sean Hannity was giving Donald
Trump advice and continues to give
Donald Trump advice on the phone just
make it official just get the guy in
there and have FoxNews actually run
White House comms yeah this is the Fox
News - Trump administration pipeline if
you want to work for the Trump
administration you don't have to become
an expert in any field you don't have to
be a politician and work your way up
through the ranks now just work for Fox
News first they'll hire you it's a kind
of regulatory capture in Reverse right
regulatory capture normally means when
you have a regulatory agency that gets
taken over by people from the industry
that they're supposed to be regulating
so like if the oil executive takes over
secretary secretary the Department of
Energy now you've got oil executives
regulating oil companies as an example
this is an example of an administration
being taken over by the media outlets
that are supposed to be reporting on the
administration and keeping them
accountable and don't underestimate the
way that this could backfire for Bill
Cheyne he could end up like Anthony
scaramouche II on CNN within months
crying about how unfairly everything
happened or whatever
it all seems great right now for Bill
Shine but it's very easy to end up on
Donald Trump's bad side and things go
very very poorly for you could happen to
Bill shine still yeah I can't wait to
see the Trump administration staffed
with Fox News executives and hosts I
know you talked about Supreme Court
Justice Jeanine Pirro right maybe you'll
see vice president Tucker Carlson press
secretary Sean Hannity yeah this goes on
and on bringing a new level of respect
to the office of the bow tie would be
Tucker Carlson as vice president they're
related to what we were talking about
earlier in the show it should be really
difficult for Bill Cheyne to have dinner
at a public restaurant I'm not talking
about violence I'm not talking about
criminality but people expressing their
views in public is totally legal and if
you ask me what I really think about
this I think it should have been Sean
Hannity just to point Hannity and forget
about it because I think Hannity is
probably better than bill shine at this
don't you think come on I mean Hannity
makes way too much money over fox he's
not gonna take a position with a lower
salary
I don't think bill shine is getting a
paying
to do this the salary for these
positions is usually think about a
hundred and fifty thousand and you know
bill Cheyne was making way more than
that at Fox News right I mean am I wrong
was he not making more than because I
wanted it's gone from Fox now right if
he's making zero now than it is more
money that is true today's program is
sponsored in part by fruit or the tour
is a social forecasting game where
players come together and compete with
each other to predict future events you
open up the game on your phone or web
browser you'll see a whole range of
forecasts covering topics across the
board politics sports so much more you
wager on predictions about real world
events using food tours in game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on for tour you can find my account
by clicking the link in the description
if you're watching this on YouTube and
this week on future I posed the question
will robert molars trump russia
investigation end during this year
during 2018 what do you think place your
bets and you can sign up now at fruit or
calm and start making your forecasts on
political topics and so many other
topics it's free and it's available on
both Android and iOS as well as on web
browsers and right now on foote or you
can win cash prizes for correct
predictions about the World Cup
check it out at fut you you are calm